[Music]
in that's nasty news that matinee
submitted by sleeping on Legos ouch oh
that could be therapeutic or not seen
those mattress topper thing is I hope
okay yeah we're gonna wake up looking
ugly you're gonna wake up with LEGO
pieces all up on you she's your [ __ ]
yeah what come look like an octopus all
over your face chuckles look what that's
a Chinese restaurant was busted washing
their pots and grill tops in a local
lake well hmm wait oh my god that's like
400 years ago yeah wait is that weird I
guess it depends on the lake yeah well
if it's in China it's like Oh everybody
does it is there soap is this somewhere
else well technically it's in shock
what's as a Chinese restaurant it's
awesome
okay I thought it was in like China okay
yeah that might get China doesn't
everyone piss in the lake [ __ ] wash it
like gutter grease gun cook with it what
yeah cuz I was like doesn't it take more
work to go to the lake and then [ __ ]
wash your [ __ ] and then bring it back
like what if the restaurants right in
front of a lake Oh like it's a like a
beachfront property kind of thingy oh I
think if it was not a lake if it was
like a stream it would be a lot better
go to the ocean but that's like saline
water right like that's the streams will
eventually make its way to the ocean
alright streams turn into rivers your
name is still technically supposed to be
like or more normally comes from our
fresh source right so with running water
a lake is like stale water it sits there
so like mosquitoes will come like things
will build up things will develop or
Daniel whereas like moving water will at
least consistently like fight off those
things deviate helps out if the grease
goes in the lake and they all support
degreaser into the lake break that down
chemically liquid plumr I guess it
depends on the proportion of the lake
versus degreasers ml solutions out there
now he's a positive person seems like
it's kind of hard to take him down well
we'll try water then I picture like a
little Chinese grandma like straight up
squatting and just scrubbing away at the
lake while there's kids and inner tubes
and [ __ ] playing so yeah there's a video
that was cut and or captured and and so
I was posted on Facebook so the
explanation from the restaurant is
saying that the drain had collected a
lot of grease and so they wanted to wash
their kitchen utensils somewhere where
the grease wasn't going down their drain
oh that's the reason so [ __ ] ghetto
okay so this is the video wait like
we're supposed to go oh okay that okay
that's okay then they're not even
supposed to have grease in their drinks
okay
exactly and they don't have drain Oh
what the [ __ ]
so then people here hey that's a that's
a size bucket is it we follow them yes
then anything yeah well I mean you're
not that [ __ ] far do that stake out
it's like I would get away with it
that's so funny dude they're like you
see that [ __ ] stalking us what's going
on we're gonna get robbed so yeah so
then they ended up the people that took
this video they contacted the health
department and so when they got there
they immediately shut down the
restaurant and ordered them to sanitize
everything um but by 6:30 p.m. that same
day they were back no oh I think I say
back in the think they know some people
yeah is the food good though because the
Health Department said that they gave
them an all-clear because the health
department tried their compound check in
and they were like oh clear yeah so then
they're saying that they had seen them
do this multiple times like some people
commenting they're like oh we always see
them they're always doing that yeah why
don't they use their own sink cuz it's
clogged I mean like why can't they
unclog it that's just weird or maybe
that's how nasty it is they try to
unclog you they can't even unclog it
there's so much grease in there yeah
what if they're like that's we can get
our fish anyway from the lake so you're
already eating from the lake what's the
difference
let's put the flavour back in the fish
yeah so then uh other people were in the
comment saying like you know how could
you post this destroying someone's
business I've never gotten sick from the
food there it's so clean I've been going
there for more than three years so they
they keep eating there then it's stupid
again yeah so the place is called number
one Chinese restaurant
I love it number one Chinese restorative
what are people gonna think what they
think about us
Oh Chinese restaurant honestly that [ __ ]
works though hey what if there's another
one that goes number two Chinese Reza oh
man number one taken will be number two
I know a bunch of like different
Vinnie's restaurant owners that like
just named their restaurant Chinese
restaurant and like just do a bunch of
Asian food because it's easier to get
people to walk along because people
don't know I've been amazing my favorite
Indian restaurant is called Indian
restaurant works that's what you want
what do I want today lunch I need food
it helps for SEO probably like if you're
googling Chinese restaurant it's like
number one Chinese restaurant true yeah
it'd be weird if it was like number two
on Yelp though right yeah you know
Chinese businesses they had those like
ABC or AAA or a whatever
that's actually an old-school SEO hack
that they did for the phone book yeah
that makes sense because it's the first
businesses that pop yeah it's like you
want plumbing go to a a plumbing and
it's the first or whatever that's why I
put an underscore in front of my Wi-Fi
name so that it's the first one but then
when you tell people to follow you have
to go underscore underscore underscore
underscore a and T and they're like they
miss my Wi-Fi at his house one your
handle wait I do have one in my handle
but ask me this is a [ __ ] ton of Anthony
Lee's that aren't even Asian how dare
they yeah the book also the underscore
means it's Asian eyes I'm the Asian one
is that what that is - absolutely that's
cute man thank you
good guy wait but why doesn't matter
whether or not your wife is a top
because it connects automatically
otherwise cause I live in like an
apartment building that has like a
hundred Wi-Fi what's the funniest Wi-Fi
name you've seen hardcore sex well one
is free porn yeah our building is like
free porn I wish you could see how many
people click on that yeah you should
have named your dance group AAA akin
just and then you could be number one
true cuz you're Asian really becoming
friends aren't we
this might be a popular opinion with the
rest of you except for Bart and Joe but
I say if I don't know what's going on
behind the scenes I'm okay
like I think as soon as I marry popular
opinion is it it's like it's not real
until you see is that something me like
I don't know I don't even want to think
about why why is that
unpopular for us cuz you guys are down
the MA even if you see it you guys are
still down oh you mean the food so so
the process yeah or in general though
right like we were talking about like
ugg boots earlier right and yeah off
camera if you don't know like how they
make a boost then you would yeah I mean
I wouldn't want to know how a sheep is
being killed but then if I do it still
doesn't [ __ ] with me that's what she's
saying I wouldn't I wouldn't I mean I
would prefer being ignorant though you
know what I mean yeah like I really guys
like in this case for some reason I
actually feel you want to eat there more
no no no no I feel more negative about
the snitch as [ __ ] really I'm
looking full so I look at that I'm like
yeah they're disgusting like crazy for
sure but the other people are spying on
them and to me that's a bigger crime
than me yeah I'm like why are you guys
being stalkers because they're doing a
greater they're doing a service to the
greater good
says Batman when he's [ __ ] people law
community builders doing self-righteous
no not unless should be to the
authorities unless those people have
like a previous record of being racist
towards Asians yeah yes some people felt
really my question is doesn't that kind
of go against what you're saying about
wanting to be ignorant does what go
against it are you rooting for them
bringing out the I'm not rooting for
them no so what I'm saying me because I
it's been exposed now so now um I'm
there said because now I'm not ignorant
hmm but wouldn't you rather not know
won't you be like oh why did you [ __ ]
show me that I wanted to stay ignorant
no I'm not that one yes you said you
said you uh
don't know I'm fine but as soon as I
find out that I'm like ah [ __ ] okay well
I'm on this side now so you don't blame
the [ __ ] whistleblowers yeah yeah you
root for the exposure I'm not roadie for
anyone I'm not on anyone's team so so
all I am is for this case right I'm like
I like food I'm rooting for good food
that's it the exposures come out oh man
my good foods really oh that's kind of
nasty I'm not going there anymore
I walk away and like thank you changes
her perspective on how she feels about
it but do you go thank you for showing
me yes I don't think for the exposure
that means you don't want to be angry if
your exposure ruder yeah cuz I do want
to be ignorant it's like you don't root
for the exposure but if it happens then
you're like thankful as well but you
don't actually want to be exposed I'm
still okay like like living in the
[ __ ] Oz world you know what I mean
like The Wizard of Oz or exposure why
don't you tell me that there's worms and
crickets in this hamburger now I gotta
still eat it with that knowledge of
[ __ ] not with you though I don't want
it anymore great result like I'll be
enjoying like this bomb ass meal like
that this dish at this restaurant like
oh my god is so [ __ ] amazing and then
next thing I know I pull out of hair and
it's not mine and I'm like that happened
at the buy at the blind place that we
went to on your birthday where you're
eating in the dark oh yeah I was full-on
eating and there was a hair and I'm like
I can't see if it's my color it's your
hair you said a lot we don't I probably
but it was sure I'd see here don't
bother me that much yeah me too
it is what it is I feel like it's a semi
natural elements of like you know
cooking food loves me if I can't see the
rest of the food I'm like is a tall
hairy just a bunch of it here for her
birthday we went like on an experience
when I was blind date I mean the dark
dinner in the dark that's where I yeah
but that's why because I know you guys
are the way you are I can't tell you
guys the truth no way you tell the truth
sure you tell me out just don't say it
Gary no I uh
okay and I'm like wait five hours after
you eat by the way you just ate lamb
dick no he tell me uh you a port that
could have been bad probably tell me
while I'm eating how you finish bean
belkin so what happen don't try to
happen with this we had pork belly that
was left over right it says it's best
salt by August 24th it's August 27th my
Asian sides like this is really good so
did you smell it I smell it the data is
always our yeah yeah they were [ __ ] you
didn't see it not so I smelled it I
smell oh you're getting emotional over a
[ __ ] not that over evidence you
literally told me the evidence you know
so what happened was I had the pork
belly smell better
Oh is he making me feel crazy no you're
crazy you're Chris I smelled it and I'm
like okay cool pork belly it smells good
it's ready to be cooked then I look at
it closely and there's all these little
bumps all of them so I look over that
you didn't even know that's not to wash
them off I wash the bumps off dead I
think it diarrhea I wash the bumps off
of here
I die wants me to live I grow them we
ate it tastes really good okay and then
after and then it was literally like he
saw me take the last bite of pork he
waited for me to chew it and it goes hey
can I tell you something
laughter [ __ ] you got your nutrients and
Salmonella yes but didn't you have
diarrhea no exactly
I don't trust you anymore should see but
the way you say it dude with the bumps
and all that or what the vlogging camera
yeah I woulda ate it yeah yeah but I'm
not you are I'm your [ __ ] dick green
slime coming out of it I washed it off
what you liked it pretty might believe
those things make me stronger and then I
read an article about botulism and I go
thank God I'm invincible
[Music]
[Music]